bonjour alors j'ai la charge de vous
expliquer ce que c'est que la créativité
selon moi alors c'est pas facile parce
que moi je passe mon temps dans mon
atelier entre quatre murs travailler sur
des petites plaques de cuivre qui vont
faire des gravures là je dois parler
devant une centaine de personnes
ça me demande un certain courage donc
cette notion de courage je pense qu est
importante
en premier lieu je pense que la création
demande du courage celui de pas se
laisser tenter par la facilité la
tendance ou le système je pense qu'on
est créatif toute sa vie de créateur et
je pense même aussi qu on est créatif
par nature donc moi quand j'étais petit
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps tout seul
dans mon coin
est ce que j'avais pas envie peut-être
qu'on me dise ce que je devais faire
donc je passais beaucoup de temps à
dessiner comme ça mais j'adorais ça et
c'était un peu tout ce que je faisais
quand j'avais du temps dit problème
c'est que ça ne s'est jamais arrêté et
il a fallu que je continue dans cette
voie là parce que c'était pour moi
c'était très important
alors je suis rentrée dans une école
d'art après le
après mes études primaires enfin le
lycée et dans cette école d'art on m'a
appris à travailler avec les méthodes du
19e siècle s'appelait l'académie julian
cette école et là on vous apprenait à
travailler avec des trucs aussi barbare
que ça bon je sors un jouet dans la
bouche qui s'appelle fil à plomb et donc
on avait la charge de dessiner à partir
de mesures prises avec des outils comme
celui là il ya la fin de cette année je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais appris
beaucoup de choses et j'étais très
content de savoir tout ça je me disais
ça y est enfin je sais dessinée super et
après j'étais aux beaux-arts de paris et
aux beaux-arts de paris me dis bah mon
petit gars c'est pas du tout ça
le dessin c'est pas travailler avec des
méthodes comptes a apprises mais c'est
plutôt travailler avec ta sensibilité
ton coeur finalement donc j'étais un peu
déstabilisé il a fallu bien que je me
l'a fallu tu me rendre à l'évidence que
ces gens là qui m'avait dit ça il avait
raison j'ai compris que ce que j'avais
cherché jusqu'à lors c'était des
certitudes tva des profs qui vous disent
une tête s'est fait comme ça
un arbre s'est fait comme ça une maison
c'est un toit rouge etc
après c'est difficile de se dire
finalement tous à savoir rien donc
j'étais un peu paumée mais j'ai compris
que tout ce qui compte dans la création
c'est de ne pas avoir de certitude et
plutôt d'aller chercher ce qu'on connaît
pas donc je pense que là la création en
tout cas en ce qui me concerne c'est
plutôt une forme de découverte c'est une
aventure bonnart disent elles à la
peinture celle aventures du nerf optique
donc on garde l'idée d' aventure donc on
découvre ce qu'on va faire
donc le créateur quelqu'un qui va faire
quelque chose qui ne sait pas qui ne
connaît pas et va le découvrir
donc on est un peu comme un comme un
archéologue qui va qui va aller sur un
site
donc il est armé la calotte il a des
connaissances
il sait à peu près oui wallemme il sait
pas ce qu'il va trouver
donc il va creuser il va trouver quelque
chose il va le garder l'année dans sa
poche et puis ça se trouve il a envie
d'aller plus loin donc il va continuer
et il a trouvé quelque chose encore plus
intéressant je pense que la création
c'est toujours aller chercher quelque
chose de plus intéressant
finalement donc après il ya il n'y a pas
de mode d'emploi
si vous voulez à partir du moment où
c'est on est sûr de rien eh bien il faut
quand même se débrouiller pour faire
quelque chose donc on a des outils moi
j'avais les miens j'ai appris la
peinture j'ai appris le dessin elle
quand j'aborde la question de savoir
comment représenter par exemple
mademoiselle qu'en face de moi je suis
complètement désarmé parce que je suis
devant quelque chose de complètement
nouveau je ne sais pas traduire
autrement que par des moyens que je n'ai
pas encore trouvé
c'est à dire parce que bon jeu j'ai donc
tout misé outils en main je sais a
priori de ces peindre gérer beaucoup de
peinture mais ces outils vont pas
forcément de servir à mentir à
à transpercer le mystère de ce qui se
présente devant moi il faut que je
trouve d'autres solutions parce que même
si j'ai fait des tas de portraits tout
ce que j'ai fait avant ne peux
absolument pas me servir à faire le
portrait en question donc c'est toujours
ça la question
et même si on n'est pas trop abstrait je
pense qu'on peut pas faire une peinture
et puis une autre pareille et puis notre
pareil chaque fois le problème
complètement nouveau donc il vous est
brouillé avec ça donc ça peut être un
peu de nos l'occasion d'une d'une lutte
sans merci entre l'artiste et le travail
qu'il fait entre le peintre et la toile
si vous voulez et parfois c'est une
vraie bagarre parce que vous bagarrer
avec wozzeck avec vos certitudes avec
votre culture et aussi avec votre envie
de faire quelque chose de différent donc
tout ça c'est toujours un peu la
pagaille dans votre tête et sur ce que
vous faites si je fais un tableau il ya
tout ça qui se mélange bien je veux
faire quelque chose je crois que je sais
le faire mais si je fais ce que je sais
faire ça marche pas donc faut trouver
autre chose parce qu on jure quelque
chose de différent chose de très fort
quelque chose qui ait une identité
quelque chose qui qui me reflète en même
temps mais qu'ils soient soi même et
donc je vais mettre tout ce que je peux
faire en jeu mais tous les moyens dont
je dispose pour faire quelque chose
et j'arrive à une espèce de bouillie si
vous voulez où tout se mélange et puis à
un moment donné quelque chose se passe
qu est ce quelque chose c'est ce qui
compte le plus dans la création c'est à
dire c'est quelque chose que vous n'avez
pas prévu qui apparaît comme ça alors
c'est vous qui l'avez fait et en même
temps c'est pas vous qui l'avez fait ce
qu'il a fait c'est plutôt leurs terres
pleuvent se montre sous un jour
différent parce que vous avez un
jugement différent ce jour là par
exemple vous
saisie autre chose et vous voyez votre
tableau comme ça dans le coin et puis il
vous montre autre chose que ce que vous
avez voulu mettre dessus j'ai pas qu'on
vous explique à ses très bizarre mais ce
n'est pas qu'une impression mais tout
est là donc le mérite de l'artiste du
créateur et de savoir reconnaître à quel
moment
l'oeuvre prend les commandes et l'oeuvre
vous emmène là où vous finalement vous
avez envie d'aller c'est à dire vers
quelque chose que vous n'avez pas fait
c'est peut-être mystérieux mais je pense
que ça se passe comme ça picasso disait
la peinture me fait faire ce qu'elle
veut c'est tout à fait ce phénomène donc
le créateur va être capable d'admettre
que ce qu'il fait peut lui échapper et
même doit lui échapper
sinon c'est pas de la création c'est
sait faire ce qu'on sait faire c'est
tout donc quand on arrive à ce point de
de sa création sur les de l'oeuvre qu'on
est en train de faire moi j'ai envie de
parler de porte
c'est à dire que l'oeuvre que vous avez
fait est en train de faire c'est
vraiment à vos yeux sous un jour nouveau
vous ouvre une porte dans cette porte
vous devez vous engouffrez vous devez
pénétrer par cette porte est allé
chercher dans la direction qu'on vous
montre jusqu'à la finale si la
finalisation de du tableau si vous
voulez ou tableaux de la culture ou
d'autres choses
ce que je pense que ces choses-là sont
finalement lors du général ça doit être
comme ça un peu pour tout le monde qui
se dit créateurs voilà je pense que j'ai
dis pas ce que je voulais merci beaucoup